people get overwhelmed so easily to
these days there's so much coming at us
and we let it come at us through
technology very often you've been a
lifelong meditator I love if you just
tell us how important that's been what
meditation is meant to you and how could
that as one of many tools be useful for
people during times like this uh
whatever success I've had has come more
from meditation than any other thing any
other
influence and um you and I um no because
you you're you're a meditator your
wife's a meditator we meditated in your
um room your meditation room um we know
what it is and I'll explain what it is
um um it it it I'll first explain what
it gives you and then I'll explain how
it gives you gives it to you um it gives
you an equinity a ability to almost rise
above yourself and to see things in this
um thoughtful way almost like uh a ninja
in a u Ninja movie as things are coming
at them everything s to seems slower and
you approach it and you can deal with it
in that way and it gives you um a
greater level of creativity and it does
that by uh connecting your subconscious
to your conscious it achieves that by
repeating a mantra so here's how it
works there's a sound that doesn't have
a meaning it's a sound we could for
example it could be something like
oh and mentally you repeat that over and
over again you close your eyes you get
uncomfortable position and you repeat
that and you'll find that your mind will
go to that but then it'll go to thoughts
and you just say oh it's in thoughts and
you go back to home and you get to
practice it and what after a while
you'll s stay in that meditation that
Mantra and then when you're in that
Mantra um it will then disappear and
then you go into a Transcendent state in
other words you transcend and you're
going basically into your subconscious
and you're in your subconscious and your
subconscious is really what controls you
more than your conscious you know it's
just you're just not conscious of it
because when you're conscious you you
know you think oh well what do I want to
do and so on but your subconscious
has such an influence of the things
you've learned in your earlier years or
your genetics or something and they're
not aware from you and when you go down
into that um you get relief but you also
um help to make the connection between
your subconscious and your conscious and
so when they're aligned you're aligning
your emotional decisions with your
intellectual decision so I find uh uh
it's an instinctual thing for me to do
what do I feel feel emotionally what do
I feel what do I do think about that
intellectually and then how do I
approach that in that calm way it
doesn't diminish your emotions um uh it
just is you feel them differently and my
my love is as much as it as ever been my
um or more maybe because I feel it
differently so I just want to emphasize
it doesn't take away your emotions or
anything it just puts them in the
perspective as though and you look above
yourself and you see yourself within the
life's Arc you see the strengths and the
weaknesses and how to deal with them and
you navigate better